welcome to this video playing GD once
again this is a very frequent opponent
12 games oh no his son that he's got a
bad score 9 wins for me 3 losses no draw
it
ok so he's going for the exchange
variation of the French yeah that's not
too exciting or maybe I should have done
something a bit more as symmetrical but
again this is um this is solid trying to
get the night over to g6 young I go
Bishop to d6 is he going to play Knight
e5 no I can't go Queen c7 ok just them
exchanging the [ __ ] is quite helpful -
um - um organize my forces and that's
not too bad yellow black so probably
about equal disposition mm-hmm the hour
is ticking here
I want night a forum in the position so
I'm not okay
Michael Knight f4 here it's playing
queen of three yeah this is not so great
okay maybe get the night over to e6 I
want I wanted to have the possibility to
play f6 at some moment maybe rook e8 +
f6 could be an eidm
yeah of course there's not much
happening here so very equal this
position for example he came near for
instance you can just take here and
continue with a normal move rook e1 for
instance rook e8 Queen d1 and it's very
very equal ish yeah no okay this is also
possible of course mmm yeah I can take
sort of maybe maybe mmm it's there at
least it's a bit a bit and even if I
take the pawn structure me yeah it's
actually a bit stupid to think about
this 19 it is really not so attractive
so I probably must take and now let's
say Ruby ain't yeah probably working it
therefore I have g5 this this I think is
quite comfortable so I am expecting to
play rook e1 or this one okay so
interesting now I could go up to f5
exchange this maybe pin my bishop is not
especially great on d7 don't he cannot
really avoid the traitor I think yeah
now I have maybe night to e6 he six is a
very nice spot for the night if I get in
c5 96 this kind of thing it would be
quite nice c5 I can do that here
c5 he probably is before that that's a
bit uncomfortable
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
play enough in a way that I have maybe
some ideas to play for when it's it's
it's very equal but hissy five porn is a
slight liability m-- and this the square
only six is very comfortable for my
night but if I go night here
they'll probably play ninety four and
it's not so clear that I have
accomplished something this is why I
would like to play c5 but then he's got
this before mover just a bit a bit
unpleasant mmm
yeah well h5 I don't mind age five so
much okay maybe I should do this after
all
ninety-four is not the end of the world
I can also play 95 well that's actually
an interesting idea 95
okay
okay.i for it's not even if I guess okay
maybe get the get the King and into the
game to e7 okay mmm yeah well h5 is this
really good could not clear well I
prevented for the moment but it's not
clear hmm it's also not clear that I
really prevented but okay going over to
c6 with the King I have a four against
three majority that has some chances to
advance the King here if he goes before
now for example I have a b6 and he
cannot enter on the B far because Norma
King is observing this okay I'm slowly
trying to progress him b5 be five days
before JH I don't want I go a5 first on
a 4f B 5 okay interesting if if I take
it now he's got this is six moves that's
that's a bit unpleasant okay I rather
let him take
no let's let's go forward to him I guess
before you cannot go to default at the
moment no I can put it on c5 interesting
time warning yeah okay let's get ahead
on the cool side okay if I take here now
he will go to the seventh it's not not
very comfortable okay but I can go King
to d5 King c3 King g5 making sure that
is six is not coming
I believe Joe okay I have ideas
it's not like I'm without any chances I
can try to enter with the king
okay well you six is a serious threat
maybe this is too risky but I can I get
g3 I just gotta get six that strong mmm
but okay um the position is okay for me
okay
check now became that's was it wrong
check draw a third oh really you're
playing on time
yeah well considering the score that you
have I understand that probably no other
way to win check game Brown and now and
then he allows a repetition who's
understanding that okay hmm yeah maybe
did I have some chances still here I
don't know it was a very very low on
time yeah I think at some point it was
rather comfortable I thought like here I
mean not not like I'm winning or
anything but I think like I saw is in
good shape him I have his majority
blocked rather okay and I can do some
advances on my own maybe maybe I should
have played really just seafoam Jack
something like that
nobody's 94 yeah 90 forests okay for him
really okay
see how probably it is just them just
equal now tried hard to breathe some
life into this position check yeah yeah
maybe default a default as an
interesting move this is what I should
have tried actually after 96 I have this
very nice intermediate move and that is
he shouldn't allow so something like
that is probably going to happen I don't
know this is this this kind of stuff can
get very interesting I'll get get here
yeah he's very active him yeah I can
take no probably need to take him check
Jim yeah probably this is going to end
in a draw somehow getting all the pawns
yeah it's tough sometimes to get some
life into this exchange friends stuff
okay thanks for watching